[Music]
do you guys remember
charlie and the chocolate factory yeah
the first one
i just talked about the johnny depp one
uh either one the first one is way
better
first one the story the book or
every time the kids got [ __ ] up i was
like yes you don't deserve it you
[ __ ] but let's talk about the it's good
sir deserve the what the candy
no they don't the ownership the
ownership ownership right yeah like
remember that was it gunther the fat kid
that [ __ ] died in the chocolate
uh yeah i was like yeah you [ __ ] what
about the one that's like
i want it now blueberry [ __ ] baruca
salt
yeah or the or the bubble gum boy
blueberry is a separate one
yeah oh no no one's the bubblegum boy
the one that blows tv
the tv the johnny something huh write
his name anyway there's a lot of kids in
that movie but the point is
that they were all trying to win a candy
factory
and so in real life now we're not in
movie land anymore in real life
there is an opportunity for you to win
a candy factory yeah but it probably
doesn't even have a chocolate
river yeah i don't want that can you
lick the walls
oh do the snozzberries taste like schnoz
berries did you look anything inside of
it and taste
as a flavor when you go to a candy
factory though it just looks like
a really boring metal shop and it's full
of like ex-cons working but if you owned
it you can make it pretty
i know but then when you think of a
candy factory you think of like
these cute small people and then like
unicorns and maybe grandmas like making
your food right
and then you show up and it's like all
these ex-cons that are like tatted up
and they don't you know
they're just kind of like on a work
release program and stuff that's cute
you put them in little aprons
well you get to hire your employees to
this factory so you can
pick whoever you want i like to give x
cons a job but then it just
destroys my image of candy how about
just cute ex-cons
yeah all right i think we can do that
they're the cutest ex-cons
i picture like uh like rats that are
crawling upside
down and then they fall into the liquid
chocolate and then they float over and
now oh god
all these like chocolate covered wraps
why do you think of that
that's what i think of candy factory
where the chocolate covered rat came
from though yeah yeah
what kind of his factory's in china his
factories in china
are there rats everywhere yeah yeah
pretty much all right not in a food safe
facility
so david klein he is the man behind
jelly belly jelly beans
giving away jelly belly the name brand
one no no he's giving away one share
to a kid no so what he so he is behind
the branding of jelly belly
but jelly belly is a family-owned
business he's not involved in it anymore
since the 80s he's just trying to name
drop
yeah it's pretty much name-dropping but
he does own
candy candy making factories so he
decided to because of this current
pandemic and how everything just feels
like [ __ ] he's like you know what
this country needs a little pick-me-up
so what he's doing is
he bought these dog tags actually i'll
let him tell you yeah
let's hear him i hope he looks like
willy wonka too
he should have dressed for this yeah
does he have a purple suit oh close
oh you got a hat he's willy wonka all
right here we go
hi everybody i'm stephanie i'm the candy
man he invented jelly belly jelly beans
oh he invented it no uh
according to jelly belly the coffee
they're like uh no he didn't he was the
one who that
that was responsible for the branding
and the name as far as like from what i
understood from jelly belly's
statement he didn't invent so he's a
liar what a [ __ ] fraud
i don't know i i could be wrong but we
hate him that's what i understood okay
here we go
we are doing the goldticket.com treasure
hunt
what is the treasure hunt about david
it's going to be
a treasure hunt across the whole entire
country
where we're going to be hiding these
right here you've already hidden
quite a few of them we're going to be
hiding them in every state across
the country wow some point after you've
gotten them in every state and had
families go out looking for them with
the possibility
of winning five thousand dollars what
are you going to do
you're gonna have a treasure hunt for
what we're gonna have the ultimate
treasure hunt where the winner will be
receiving a
key to our candy one of our candy
factories
that's exciting absolutely i hope
everybody considers joining the game
and signs up for one of the treasure
hunts we're looking for you
charlie out there what do you get with
the key
you just could open it and then go to
the city but keep to the candy factory
well it's you it is it is you owning it
did jelly belly come out and say
hey uh he doesn't own these factory
either so please don't please don't come
here
you just see now this guy's down he's
some
it honestly reminds me of something joe
would do he's like i got these
buried all around the country
that's like my future very true so when
they asked him like what would hap
what is going to happen after someone
wins the candy factory he says there
probably will be some taxes that will
have to be paid
and that you should consult your
accountant so he probably owes on taxes
already
i just need a babe that's what i was
thinking too i need someone to take over
this business
i got an idea let's throw it at some
poor schmuck
dude imagine some poor schmuck getting a
candy factory now they're like [ __ ] i
gotta make candy
have you guys seen the the show
succession because that's pretty much
like what happened in that show too like
he wanted his father's company so bad
and the moment he gets it
he finds out it's actually three billion
dollars in debt and
like it's pretty [ __ ] fun isn't that
what was happening with oprah's like
giveaway like you get a car you did it
and then was like i got a [ __ ] car
and then they had to pay taxes on this
like you can't afford this car
the registration is a thousand dollars
yeah
yeah so that he did mention that and
that uh you will
hire your own employees and so
currently because i checked for
california oh because by the way the
in order to participate you have to pay
49.98
per like for your entry for the ticket
hey that's not legal
remember it's not legal you you it
should be i think in california
specifically
uh there's a lot of purchase necessary
exactly that no purchase necessary he
doesn't look very legal though oh okay
i don't know but yeah what are you lied
about jellybelly for treasure hunts it
can't be a purchase
no it can't cause we we're i don't this
is so weird that this willy wonka
concept's happening because literally
this month of september we're hosting
our own
uh yeah golden ticket campaign for the
whole month of september where we hide
uh three tickets for people to win 500
bucks each
um but then for us we needed to put in
the fine print
california law saying no purchase
necessary maybe they're not in
california
no so it's in every single state of the
entire country
and so that's i checked on his website
in california
tickets are already sold out so a
thousand people in california or for
for the california treasure hunt have
already purchased you got to go to a
state like
idaho that has less compet competition
no but every single state
sold out oh i don't know if every single
state is going to be sold out but i do
know that he's
he's doing this in every single state up
to a thousand people can join
per state yeah so i'm saying to increase
your chances you want to go to a low
population state
and then you know that they're probably
gonna hide it in the major city which is
like
one yeah so your probability is probably
much higher than there he gave
clues i think right wait a minute i
think he gave clues
uh so that's how you find it yeah so
once you purchase your entry then that's
how
initially you end up getting added to
this facebook group page but then now
they're moving away from facebook and
trying to make it on the website but the
point is you get added to some sort of
group
and then they'll either text you or
email you whatever clues
and then like somehow like little by
little they give you clues
in forms of riddles it definitely feels
like it owes money because it's 50 bucks
just to like maybe find a 5 000 ticket
yeah it's a ponzi dude
he needs money yeah what does selling
out mean in that state
is it a thousand how many people how
many tickets a thousand tickets right
because oh
they're selling and that's like fifty
thousand dollars times fifty states
yeah he's looking for charlie bucket
that's like 2.5 million charlie bucket
couldn't afford 50 bucks
it's like you get five thousand dollars
well i get two point five million yes no
i invented jelly belly
yeah for tomorrow for doc gold dog tags
that are probably
14k plated no not even like real gold
yeah it could just be brass too and then
and then he said a chance to win five
grand so it's like does
does that mean every state you get five
grand two
i think you win five grand for the dog
tag but you a chance to get
the factory yeah so when you get the dog
tag you get five grand
oh that's a lot of money i think we've
almost sucked all of the joints
i think okay well we're close the
business seems a little shady is all
well i mean okay it's like the lotto
right if you
are the winner you you paid 50 to make
five grand that's cool but it just
started off with a lie that's the part
that kind of throws it
i think that's what it that's what it
was it's like i wanted to be excited
about it but then it was like
this sounds shady so wait what is that
is that
25 000 max he'll be paying out and then
he gets 2.5 million
five times fifty five times or five
thousand fifty thousand okay
five thousand yeah oh that's 250
thousand didn't charlie
like he could only afford two candy bars
i think he only got one he only got one
right
every no he got one and then his grandpa
got another yeah yeah you're right not
50 bucks bro yeah looking for charlie
[ __ ]
good luck with that and that was the
only time chocolate looked actually
appetizing for me yeah
you don't like chocolate no it was like
this big not that much like a big old
bar and i'm like oh
that foil wrapper you unfold it i hated
chocolate back then
really yeah i didn't like it i liked it
when it was melted
oh what about like that i would leave it
in the car and get it melted
and you're just like licking it off yeah
i like to lick it off the wrapper
yeah i only like chocolate like dipped
uh
ice cream like you know how they dip
that was it like drumsticks that's me
now
the only thing i hated about chocolate
is i had a blankie
and then i always yeah and i had a uh my
chocolate yeah he had a little chocolate
yeah and i was eating my chocolate
chocolate two years ago yeah
and that should be like melting all over
my blanket so by the time i want to
snuggle my blankets all nasty oh they're
gonna say it looks like [ __ ]
chocolate's fault [ __ ] chocolate so i
learned to put my blankie on the side if
i'm enjoying my chocolate
oh what a gentleman that's like me now
you put your blanket to this side you
have chocolate covered blankets
chips and salsa all over my blanket you
should it's your [ __ ] blanket
dude she spilled wine last night on the
floor of our closet and i got the stain
out closet why is it in the closet
are you looking at clothes like this
like you're at a thrift shop shopping
i don't judge your life
i don't eat in my closet why are you
eating your closet for i don't judge
your life she was shopping
look she was shopping in her closet you
have a blankie she didn't say
[ __ ] she's like that's what i was like
five years old
they'll have that blanket you sleep with
it yes no
that's five so you have a you have a
blank chocolate ring i have a real
blanket
i have a duvet i would it's see-through
bro i'm a duvet
you